the Joe Rogan experience that the fear
of death and the attitude of the finite
life being insignificant that the like
what is the point this sort of
existential angst that many of us
struggle with right yeah right that's
something that you touch upon really
early on that this this thing that makes
us unique is that we know that we're
gonna die yeah yeah that that to me is
the vital distinguishing feature of our
species you know we can reflect on the
past we can think about the future and
recognize that we're not going to be
here in the future these for some period
of time
and it's um it's an idea and it's
powerful motivating influences one that
has been explored throughout the ages
Auto ronk who's one of the early
disciples of Freud who ultimately broke
with Freud developed this thesis that
our awareness of our own mortality is
one of the driving factors in what we do
and then when I was I don't know I was
in my 20s or 30s I read a book by a guy
named Ernest Becker called denial of
death I'm have you ever heard of this
book it was it was big in the 70s and
one actually the Pulitzer Prize in the
70s and it's a wonderful distillation of
this way of thinking about why we humans
do what we do and in many ways in my own
book the one that's coming out actually
today you until the end of time it's um
it's extending this notion that Becker
developed in denial of death but now
seeing it in a cosmological setting
because it's not just we that are going
to die it's every structure in the
universe is going to disintegrate in
time our our best theory suggests to us
that even protons the very heart of
matter there are quantum processes that
in the far future will ensure that every
proton disintegrates falls apart into
its constituent particles and at that
point there's no complex matter around
at all what are the would timeline are
we talking well a pretty pretty big long
timeline in fact I'd like to use a
metaphor to try to give you a feel for
the time
involved I like to use the Empire State
Building and imagine that every floor of
the Empire State Building represents
adoration ten times out of the previous
floor so like on the ground floor it's
like one year first floor ten your
second floor 100 and so forth so you're
going exponentially far in time as you
climb up the Empire State Building and
in that scheme of things everything from
the Big Bang until today you're about at
the tenth floor
ten to the ten years ten billion years
and as you go forward you are looking at
things very far in the future and to
answer your question we think and i
underscore think because we're now at
the speculative end of our theoretical
ideas protons will decay roughly and say
by the 38th floor so 10 to the 38 years
into the future so we can relax for a
little bit you can relax for a little
bit but here's here's the thing the
amazing thing obviously is it sounds
trite but time is relative right so any
duration that seems long it's only long
by comparison to another duration and on
say the scale of the entire empire state
building up to say ten to the hundred
years into the future which is what the
peak would represent 10 to the 38 years
is like less than a blink of an eye I
mean it's nothing on those scales so you
sort of have to be careful whether
you're your intuition if you're willing
to entertain the kind of fantastically
long time scales that you necessarily
need to if you're going to think about
the very far future is there speculation
as to what happens when protons do cease
to exist yeah
we anticipate that all complex structure
will fall apart so if there any star is
left over we believe that by the 14th
floor most stars will have used up their
nuclear fuel there will be dark embers
just sort of you know smoky out there in
the cosmos but if they're still hovering
around by the 38th floor they will all
just dissipate into their particular
ingredients so it's hard to imagine past
safe floor 38 that there's going to be
any life for any mind or any complex
astronomical structures out there in the
universe so the window within which the
universe as we
it exists it's kind of small when you
think about it in terms of the entire
cosmic timeline so impossible to
understand the actual span of it because
it is so long but yet so small like yeah
in the human mind yeah it's very hard to
hold these durations yeah in mind I mean
I don't I don't feel like I've been
thinking about this stuff for a long
time I don't feel like I have an
intuition for the durations that we are
talking about in fact the Empire State
Building that little analogy helps me to
sort of give some relative sense of when
things of interest will happen in the
universe but you know we're good at
understanding days weeks months years
the times of you know conventional
experience we have no basis for
understanding the universe over these
scales that we've never experienced you
know and that's true not only for time
it's also for space right I mean we have
very good intuition about everyday
phenomena I mean if I have to take this
bottle of water I throw it at you you'd
catch it you know where to put your hand
you didn't have to calculate it's
Newtonian trajectory to figure out where
the water is going but if I was to do
the same thing with electrons you don't
have a neither do I a quantum intuition
about the wave functions and the
probabilities that govern how a particle
like an electron behaves and that's
simply because we were unfortunately or
fortunately born as big creatures
relative to the scales of quantum
mechanics and because of that our
intuition was never under any
evolutionary pressure to understand how
electrons behave in fact I like to say
those of our forebears wandering around
the African savannah who started to
think about electrons in quantum
mechanics they got eaten right they're
the ones whose genes didn't propagate
onward and therefore those of us who are
the beneficiaries of the survival of our
ancestors were good at understanding
Newtonian physics but we're not good at
understanding anything else about the
deep reality of the world do you
anticipate that someday in the future
whatever is next after human beings will
be able to understand these concepts
because if you stop and think about what
human is we've only really been this for
X amount a hundred thousand years that's
right and it's a it's a good question
and it's a tough one
I'd like to imagine that as we get ever
better at creating virtual worlds
virtual reality or whatever augmented
reality whatever version of that kind of
technology takes over in the far future
we might be able to experience these
distinct realms in such a powerful way
that our innate intuition may begin to
shift to change so that we grasp the
quantum realm the way we grasp Newtonian
physics I can at least imagine that as a
possibility what it would take to
actually get there and whether our
species will ever last long enough to
actually have that kind of an impact on
our intuition I don't know but it's all
about experience and survival we have
been programmed by evolution not to
understand the true nature of the world
we've been programmed by evolution to
survive and those are two radically
different propositions because you don't
need to know the true nature of reality
to survive it's a distinct attribute and
one that is not necessarily one that has
any survival value to understand black
holes or the Big Bang or general
relativity or quantum mechanics or
entropy or thermodynamics these
qualities we develop as we go forward
and try to understand the world go
beyond mere survival and figure out
things that excite us but it's not
something which obviously has any
survival value it may someday MA
[Applause]